Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
the thing that troubles me the most,
they here in the country is it we become
so partisan.
Uh,
I remember when I first joined the
congress way back,
1980,
uh,
there was a rule,
you know,
the partisanship stops at the water's
edge.
That's blown,
that's gone.
Uh,
there,
there was a time in that,
in that history when I joined the
congress,
when one party has such a commanding
presence in the Congress or the other
never even thought about gaining
control.
Well,
I got along now they both realize they
can control things if they just destroy
each other sufficiently.
I mean,
the,
the lesson of the Republican takeover of
the house was it,
uh,
you know,
if you could,
if you could tear down institutions so
dramatically in the eyes of the American
public,
you can take it over.
Uh,
that's been repeated now,
uh,
in,
in the last election cycle.
And it will be repeated again if
partisanship is,
is so important in this country that,
that,
that people are willing to,
you know,
to just attack each other rather than
debate each other's ideas.
There was a,
there was a better tutorial I think in
one of the news magazines going way
back.
I remember I talked about the impact of
television and negative campaigning upon
the politics of our country.
And um,
I made the case that,
you know,
television was such a powerful entity
that if you combined it with negative
campaigning and negative advertising,
you could wreck some pretty significant
damage to our system.
I think that's happened.
Like they pointed out,
you know,
if Mcdonald's and Burger King had run
ads for 10 years on television,
not talking about how good that product
right,
but how awful the other guys' products
were and I'm rotten and disease causing,
et Cetera.
We wouldn't be choosing among brands.
We would,
we would be the hamburgers anymore.
And the point that the article made was
that,
you know,
we're reaching a stage where we're not
choosing between candidates anymore.
We're turning off on the whole system
and Americans today a turning off
dramatically on the two parties and the
system,
uh,
the reputation of congress is an all
time low presidencies.
Reputation is at an all time low,
uh,
driven in large part by a willingness to
attack each other rather than the debate
our ideas as civilized human beings.
And,
and,
and I think we face a real danger here
in this country.
If it continues at some point,
respect for the institutions of our
government,
uh,
either has to recover or this old time,
lower experiencing is going to pull it
apart.
And,
and who knows what we get in its place?
Well,
I,
you know this,
there's an easy recipe and that is your
recipe is to turn out anybody who plays
negative politics and,
and start insisting that candidates
speak positively about each other and
about their ideas and debate the ideas.
And the,
the,
the national press could,
could help with that.
But obviously,
you know,
everybody likes a good fight.
So instead we like negative politics.
And as much as people say they don't
like him and you check with the
pollsters,
they work there,
they,
they literally help elect candidates.
If I can make you believe the other
guy's worse than I am,
I get your vote.
Uh,
we gotta,
we gotta recognize it.
That ain't good for the country.
We've got to change that.
We've got to literally start rewarding
positive politics in America.
Again,
we've got to start rewarding those who
were willing to reach out across the,
the,
the middle of the chasm and work
together that,
you know,
there are fewer and fewer people brave
enough to do that in America.
We've got to start rewarding them when
they do that.
We've got,
we've got to say to the Joe Lieberman
is,
we're not going to penalize you because
you're reached across the aisle and work
with,
with Republicans on something that was
important or to say the conservative
Democrats that you're going to get
penalized because you worked with
Republican Party Republicans who reach
across the aisle and work with Democrats
on a health care issue.
Whatever it is,
we've got to start saying,
that's okay.
That's not only,
okay,
that's good and we can't let the parties
run the show.